BOYD THE SECOND CENTRE ICEMAN,
GETS THE FIRST GOOD CHANCEYTON.
TRY FOR THE WRAP AROUND.
BUT HELLEBUYCK GOTOT
PIONK, NOWRE'S A QUICK SHOT
AT THE SIDE OF THE NET ANDCOLLE.
LOWRY FRONT.
NO ONE THERE TO CASH.
DYLAN WITH THE SHOTTWHEELER, WHS
ON TOP OF THE NET!
LOOKING FOR THAT FIRST GOAL AND
THAT WAS AS CLOSE AS HE COULD
GET.
A REAL G MORRISSEY, BUT NOW
HERE'S KESSEL.
RIGHT IN THE LOOK.
SENDS IT ACROSS FOR CROUSE.
TRIES FOROR
TONINATO OUT TO HARKINS, HARKINS
O FAR HAS BEEN VERY
SHARP IN THE NET.
BAD ANGLE CHANCE, HOWEVER, HE'SY
VEJMELKA.
IN HIS RKINS, ON THE MOVE,
GAINS THE ZONE. WHEELING AROUND
HE SHOOTS AND IT'S TURNED ASIDE.
VEJMELKA LOST IT BUT HE
CHANCE FOR THE WINNIPEG JETS OFF
THE RUSH.
>> Leah: KESSEL GETS THE STICK
IN FRONT, VEJMELKA WITH THE
SAVE, ON THE REBOUND I THINK
THERE WOULD BE A DEFENSEMAN.
THEY JUST KIND OF SAY, THAT'S e.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE KA WITH THE.
STILL HAS IT BUT WITH
BUT IF START TO CHEAT IN THESE
REBOUND RIGHT IN FRONT F F
PIONK WITH THE SHOT FROM THE
DUBOIS HAS IT, TAKES THE SHOT,
REBOUND IN FRONT.
DUBOIS ENDS UP WITH IT AFTER HE
KICKS IT OUT OF THE ROUSSEL AND
IN!
ANTO PERFECT TIP
GOING TO NET TO GET COYOTES THE
LEAD HERE AND YOUFRONT, VEJMEME
REAL GOOD FORECHECK BY
THE GREAT CHANCE AT THE SIDE OF
THE NET
FACEOFF AS HE'LL JUMP RIGHT OV.
THROUGH AND IT ENDHLERS.
EHLERS CUTTING DOWN THE WING,,
SCHMIDT.
SCHMIDT FAKES IT.
DUBOIS, SCHMIDT WITH THE FRONT,
THAT ONE WAS IN.
IT LOOKED LIKE ANOTHER FOOT UP
THAT ONE AND DUBOIS LOOKING FOR